rats are doubling down on censorship
they apparently don't care even after
the Biden White House got caught
colluding with big Tech to silence
conservatives Al Gora the man who wants
to credit for creating the internet
calling for a more extreme Crackdown on
social media these algorithms they are
the digital equivalent of AR-15s they
ought to be banned they really ought to
be banned it's an abuse of the public
forum but when these when people are
pulled down these rabbit holes you know
what's at the bottom of the rabbit hole
that's where the echo chamber is uh and
if you spend too much time in the Echo
chamber what's weaponized is another
form of AI not artificial intelligence
artificial
Insanity well artificial Insanity Dana
coming from the guy who created the
internet uh it's isn't it interesting
though that um there was a time when we
used to argue the the issues now we're
arguing about what information people
can access yeah I I am not sure where I
land on this because part of me feels
like you can't stop progress people have
tried to stop technology in the past it
doesn't work that way we're also very
late to get to this issue right this
it's already out there 45% of young
people already get all of their news all
of it on Tik Tok okay so the idea of
banning the social media I understand
the security reasons I also understand
the reasons that you might want to for
people mental health and just well-being
and wouldn't it be better if we could
just go back to those days I just don't
know if we can go back to those days
also I'm concerned about who then is
tweaking the algorithm like is
Washington DC going to get involved and
tweak the algorithm are they going to
Outsource that so I understand that it's
a gigantic problem in the meantime I do
think one of the best ways to deal with
content that is negative or against your
point of view whatever it is is to
provide alternate content that is as
compelling and entertaining and
interesting or humorous or whatever it
might be in order to get those eyeballs
to come down your rabbit hole and visit
other rabbit holes so I um maybe I feel
just a little bit unsure right now where
I am on it okay and you know um Jessica
that since 2020 apparently meta has
known of the vulnerability of of the
teenage brain that they can become very
susceptible and be addicted so that's
the other side well that's that's what I
thought Al Gore was talking about like
The Whistleblower in the Facebook case
um evidence that we have that algorithms
can be discriminatory against women for
instance Amazon's recruiting tool was
found to have been discriminatory
especially in terms of stem jobs or the
US Healthcare System actually was using
an algorithm that was discriminatory
against blacks it was actually
suppressing the needs of black patients
and treating them the same as white
patients and there are key differences
there so that's and I that's a worthy
cause I think for Al Gore to be talking
about and and I think it's things that
we're all concerned about ourselves you
know we you can get annoyed right I keep
getting served the same dress from sax
or whatever like that's annoying but if
you're a 13-year-old girl who struggles
with their weight and you continue to
get served pictures of anorexic girls
that make you think that you should be a
certain way it's leading to not only
need for psychiatric heal people killing
themselves um and I think Gore was
making a good point about it what where
did he come down
Jesse I think after he lost the election
lost his mind because he had no problem
with the algorithms when they were
sending him down Democrat rabbit holes
like collusion and the world's going to
end in 12 years this is about musk this
is about when musk took over and Al Gore
goes on Twitter and says we're all going
to die from rain bombs and he gets
community noted or whatever and so now
he needs to reform democracy and
capitalism he's going to take a little
time off from saving the world and he's
going to reform democracy and capitalism
the man is psychologically
psychologically obsessed with control
all Democrats are they have to control
Twitter or everyone dies they have to
control the White House they have to
control what car I drive what health
care I have imagine dating a Democrat
when are you coming home pour that drink
out I mean God they don't want a
relationship with the voters they want
ownership Greg is it true yeah well it's
weird that Al Gore wants to ban Al Gore
rhythms o
I'm confused here are we defending Tik
Tok now because we thought it was the
worst thing in the world like 6 months
ago are they advertising or something I
don't understand I hope so I mean no
honestly I mean he's got an argument for
this it's not about data capture it's
about brain capture it's about kids the
evidence is there we're seeing a rise in
mental illness mainly driven by
pernicious ideas on social media you see
when you see the Tik Tok videos what do
you see you see that the deranged all
look the same Wildey emotionally
incontinent they have the fervor of
activists and they're either mocking the
sexual atrocities or they're boasting of
indoctrinating your kids it feels like
when you're looking at Tik Tok that it's
a scop the problem is I don't like the
messages and is that why I don't want it
around what if I like the messages what
if suddenly Tik Tok encouraged American
patriotism or encourage stem education
or encourage you know doing the pledge
of allegiance would I change my mind I
think maybe I will but I haven't seen
that because that doesn't exist so the
answer really is is capturing Tik Tok
exposing the scop what x did what Elon
Musk did with Community notes
effectively removed the strangle hold
that the left had on fake news those
Community notes are doing a lot of heavy
lifting China polices Tik Tok in their
own country so their kids don't get
poisoned but our kids are we should be
able to figure out a way and I think we
will research shows that young people
would pay pay to get rid of social media
if all the kids abided by it but if they
don't they won't so basically they're
only doing social media as mutually
assured destruction think about that
think about what we have allowed into
our country it is a scop I'm agreeing
with Al
Gore okay hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else